Bruce Feldman of Fox Sports and also the
athletic back here in the Rich Eisen
show how you doing Bruce
so where do things stand is were
chatting best you could tell right now
you know at this point yesterday rich I
thought it was probably a 25% chance
that Overmeyer was down in Ohio State
and by mid-afternoon yesterday I thought
it was 50/50 and this morning waking up
I think is probably a 75% chance that
these comes to the last game you know
the text messages of Urban Meyer's where
Shelley Meyer to the X receivers coach's
wife are pretty damning and the question
is and this is the one thing I kind of
looked at and said okay this may be the
one thing that could save her an admirer
they think they're keeping them would be
you go back to the Big Ten media is two
weeks ago in Chicago and her mind was
pressed upon kind of what did he know as
it related to to Zach Smith could they
have fired him the night before and he
talked about in 2009 when they were both
in Florida that he heard about an
incident and he told his boss because
that's what you're supposed to do and
then into he many proceeded to talk
about how his wife and he got involved
you know there was some counseling and
and and different things that they were
trying to help the young couple with but
what struck me looking back is
especially in light of all this that
points in direction of the Urban Meyer
knowing something that happened of an
incident for two multiple instance in
2015 was why determined Meyer tell his
boss presumably Florida 80 Jeremy Foley
in 2009 and he wouldn't have done
anything in 2015 if he in fact knew his
keep in mind what happened at six year
gap with the Jerry Sandusky scandal at
Penn State and what that did was that
made every coach if they weren't already
very aware that when it comes to title 9
in the Clery Act there's a direct
whether you believe this person on your
staff is guilty of it or not or this
player is guilty of it or not you got to
run enough to run it up to the proper
channels to get it investigated they do
it not you and so why would he not
perhaps he did do it entree to what it
sounds like he said two weeks ago okay
so I'm trying to follow this here cuz
you're right I mean he did in 2009 say
hey I did the right thing and we we
reported it and so in 2015 you know I
unlike the 2009 incident Courtney Smith
did not go to the police there was no
file of a charge or anything like that
so to know something was going on comes
from a text exchanged between Courtney
and Urban Meyer's wife that came to
light yesterday and the Bret McMurphy
reporting so the question is is is is is
it possible in your mind that Urban
Meyer somehow some way despite Courtney
having this text exchange with his wife
and then all the other wives according
to Courtney knowing what was going on it
that this was a conversation amongst the
wives of all the coaching staff of Allah
state that Urban Meyer was still in the
dark I mean rich it's technically
possible he was still in the dark about
the part where I'm skeptical of that
side of it would be you know he told us
in the media at that press conference he
was the one who brought this part up
that he and Shelly got involved and
talked about it and this wasn't just
urban Meyer would like you know he had
some assistants come and go this was the
grandson of his mentor all the later Oh
Bruce this was a guy who was a who when
he was a first-time head coach at
Bowling Green this was a walk-on who
played for him this was the guy he
brought with him to Florida so if he's
talking about he and his wife I had
already had these conversations with
with zachsmith and his wife and and
Shelly my recording those texts that
McMurphy had reported on Shelly
if Shelly Meyer had said you know he
scares me
in regard to Zach Smith it's it seems
very odd that she wouldn't have followed
up with her husband and and she's a
nurse by the way it's not you know like
I think that adds another layer of
context she's an employee of the school
and the nursing them yeah I mean
school right yeah it seems odd that you
would have wood held some of those
details that the football operations
wife you know would know and be invested
in and that they would keep that from
Urban Meyer it just seems really strange
and that's why I know look again I go
back to this other point it's entirely
possible that Urban Meyer told his boss
Gene Smith the ad when he heard some of
this and he thought you know what
there's no there were no charges brought
you know police didn't look into you
know there was a story I guess in the in
the Cleveland Plain Dealer on their
website that they had found I want to
say nine instances that were reported
between you know over a six-year stretch
and it's entirely possible Urban Meyer
said well I told my bosses they looked
into it there was nothing there so when
I said there was nothing maybe in his
head that's how he's seeing it but right
now you know urban Myers not obviously
not commenting short of the the
statement that he he gave yesterday
right and in fact if he did in fact kick
it up the chain of command and then just
didn't want to throw his athletic
director under the bus in front of the
media in the Big Ten media group and
just decided to say I've said all I'm
required to say about it and that's it
then he's sitting at home right now
stewing saying everybody's were thinking
that I looked the other way but I
actually kicked it up the chain so Wow
I mean if that's the case then I mean
this could this could blow everything up
look we're both in the media I would say
this you know when you go through this
process and they have somebody saying
okay you're on paid leave especially
such a high-profile figure and the story
has as much visibility as it does and
also by the way you know they're about
to go report to camp you know within
hours so it's not like this happening in
the middle of the middle of the summer
you wonder so longer this happens you
know I'm watching TV at our former
Network yesterday and I'm seeing all the
you know all the college football people
weighing in on this yeah the more people
talk about it you know if there is some
level of a plausible explanation like
that you know it's like this stuff
almost becomes like calcified like
everybody's now just believed that
this is a you know he's a nice dead man
walking and look maybe that's the case
maybe he has coached his last game we
don't know but I think the more time is
gonna pass between this it's like I'd be
curious well you know what's gonna be if
there is some kind of proof that he did
have those conversations what then you'd
obviously got to explain the comments he
then made in Chicago at Big Ten media
days but it's really curious dynamic
that is kind of unfolding because Ohio
State you know within the hour just
announced that practices are closed to
the media now and all the players and
coaches are gonna be off-limits
at least until Monday till they sort
some of this out there's a lot of stuff
going on and also you wonder why didn't
Ohio State in the wake of you know his
own Smith's arrest a month ago why
didn't they start the investigation then
why didn't even they start the
investigation after Big Ten media days
this inquiry you know seems have just
started you know just within the last 24
hours
I mean why didn't they start that a lot
sooner well we're less than a month from
the beginning of the season for
everybody Bruce last one for you before
I let you go what is the biggest story
we're not talking about then because
this is taken up all the oxygen in the
college football room is it Alabama
starting quarterback what what what what
do you think needs to be front and
center otherwise yeah I would say it's
when you have a national title team with
an SEC Player of the Year how does Nick
Saban manage it I mean look I don't mean
who's gonna feel sorry for next day I
mean he's got two talented quarterbacks
and quite honestly he's got a pretty
suspect schedule this year I don't think
anybody's gonna push them too hard until
they get into November so I mean you
know that's certainly a you know a big
storyline but that gotten all blown out
on the water because you have what I
think most people consider the second
best coaching in college football and
right now his career is in jeopardy and
in large part because of all the you
know because he he basically leaned on
and entrusted a guy who whether he knew
he was a domestic abuser or not from the
start and this was a guy who had very
shaky character and it kind of goes back
to all the stuff at Florida where all
his problems came from given shaky
character guys second third and fourth
chances this
time it wasn't a player it was its an
assistant coach where it seems to be
leading to all his uh his problems now
Bruce appreciate the time thanks very
much
well chat exaggerated you got it that's
a produced of element of Fox Sports busy
be the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience